good afternoon everybody of all the
responsibilities the Constitution endow
to Congress to should be fairly simple
pass a budget and pay America's bills
but if the United States Congress does
not fulfill its responsibility to pass a
budget today much of the United States
government will be forced to shut down
tomorrow I want to be very clear about
what that shutdown would mean what will
remain open and what will not with
regard to operations that will continue
if you're on Social Security you will
keep receiving your checks if you're on
Medicare your doctor will still see you
everyone's mail will still be delivered
and government operations related to
national security or Public Safety will
go on our troops will continue to serve
with skill honor and courage air traffic
controllers prison guards those who are
with border control Border Patrol will
remain on their posts but their
paychecks will be delayed until the
government reopens NASA will shut down
almost entirely but Mission Control will
remain open to support the astronauts
serving on the space station I also want
to be very clear about what would change
office buildings were closed paychecks
will be delayed vital services that
seniors and veterans women and children
businesses and our economy depend on
would be hamstrung business owners would
see delays in raising capital seeking
infrastructure permits or rebuilding
after Hurricane sandy veterans who've
sacrificed for their country will find
their support centers unstaffed tourists
will find every one of America's
national parks and monuments from
Yosemite to the Smithsonian to the
Statue of Liberty immediately closed and
of course the communities and small
businesses that rely on these national
measures for their livelihoods will be
out of customers and out of luck and in
keeping with the broad ramifications of
a shutdown I think it's important that
everybody understand the federal
government is America's largest employer
more than two million civilian workers
and 1.4 million active-duty military
served in all 50 states and all around
the world in the event of a government
shutdown hundreds of thousands of these
dedicated public servants who stay on
the job will do so without pay and
several hundred thousand more will be
immediately and indefinitely furloughed
without pay well of course will not be
furloughed are the bills that they have
to pay their mortgages their tuition
payments their car notes these Americans
are our neighbors their kids go to our
schools they worship where we do they
serve their country with pride they are
the customers of every business in this
country and they would be hurt greatly
and as a consequence all of us will be
heard greatly should Congress choose to
shut the people's government down so
shutdown will have a very real economic
impact on real people right away past
shut past shutdowns have disrupted the
economy significantly this one would too
it would throw a wrench into the gears
of our economy at a time when those
gears have gained some traction five
years ago right now our economy was in
meltdown today our businesses have
created seven and a half million new
jobs over the past three and a half
years the housing market is healing and
our deficits are falling fast the idea
of putting the American people's
hard-earned progress at risk is the
height of irresponsibility and it
doesn't have to happen
let me repeat this it does not have to
happen all of this is entirely
preventable if the house chooses to do
what the Senate has already done and
that's the simple act of funding our
government without making extraneous and
controversial demands in the process the
same way other Congress's have for more
than 200 years